なんか明るい蓮田そうです
ブラックホールは 残念ながら外から見えない
それだけ いや こう言ったっても巨大なものだから
ものすごいエネルギー固まってあって
だから光はあります ものすごいエネルギーの塊だから
強烈な その光もすごい重いんですね
我々の光と軽いもんじゃないんです
重くて外に出られない
光の線は全部もう曲がって曲がって一つの球になっている
ですから 私たちにとっては全くの暗い存在
ブラックホールの人に電話でもしてみれば
暗くないよと言ってくれるかもしれません
ブラックホールに住んでる人々
我々の世界考えちゃうと
人間が宇宙に裸でいるような感じなんですね
我々は宇宙の方に何もなくて行っちゃったらどうなるかわからないでしょ
もう いわゆる全くの空気圧のない空間に行っちゃったら
これ中のものは全部飛び出しちゃいますからね
危ないでしょうし だからあなた方生きてるというのは大変大変なことと思うかもしれませんし
まあまあ そういうふうな次元の世界
いろいろ変わりますけど
カーマーチャーラっていうのは
とにかくこの目耳鼻という道具として知ってる世界
ですから 動物の心は何界？欲界なんです
地獄の生命は地獄 まああるかどうかは別にして
地獄の生命ももう体として感じてるんだから欲界と
神々も体を持ってるんだから欲界なんですね
ですから 心の次元は神々の心の次元も
人間の心の次元も 動物の心の次元も
動物よりも下のレベルの
例えば餓鬼とか地獄とか
そこら辺の生命の世界も同じ
欲界 幽霊もオバケもみんないるならば
ですから体に体によって知るものは違う
だからミミズが知るものと人間が知るものは違うと同じく
神々が知ってる世界と我々が知ってる世界は違う
フクロウやらコウモリに聞こえる世界と人間に聞こえる世界は違います
でもちゃんとさ 道具として知ってることだけは同じ
ですから神々が知ってる世界は違いますが
体という道具として知ってるんだから欲界
というふうになるんです
で 欲界には だから数え切れない心が生まれますけど
仏教ではだいたい 50 52 54
ぐらいのグループに分けてるんです
ですから  54 ぐらいの心を勉強すればいいんです
で 次にルーパワーチャーラ
次の次元 これがものすごい高い次元なんですね
ルーパっていうのは物質という意味で色なんですね
でも次元は高い 眼耳鼻舌身に頼ってるわけじゃないんです
これはどうやって生まれますか？例えば
人は一生懸命瞑想する
瞑想する時 どんどんどんどんこの欲が消えていっちゃうんですね
妄想も消えていっちゃうんですね
我々は見たい 聞きたいという世界でずっといるんだから
そんなものを見たく見なくたっても聞かなくたっても
味わわなくたってもいいんじゃないかと
そちらに楽しみは何もないんだと
束縛されてるだけですよと言って
欲から心が離れる このカーマから心が離れる
このカーマから心が離れるということは
我々に想像さえできないことなんです
なぜならば すべての知識概念からも離れるんだから
離れるんだけど 一応心が色に依存している
色に依存して認識する
それは扇状の状態なんです
物質に依存して活動してるんだけど
見た視覚に依存するとか
聞いた聴覚に依存するとか
そこはない まあもとはといえば
我々の知識世界 我々の認識次元はもう全部片っ端から捨てる
捨てて もっと高い次元を作る
高い次元は作ったんだけど
いまだに体という物質的な構造には何らかの関係を持っている
その次元はルーパヴァチャラというんです
ですから神々よりはすごいレベルは高いんです
まあ後でもっと説明入るんですけど
今日はただ紹介だけで
こういう心が十五種類あります
三番目にはアルーパヴァチャラという心が生まれる
それは無色界というんですね
無色界 この場合の差は
瞑想して瞑想して優れてる体験を得て
どんどんどんどん優れていったところで
じゃあ体という物質にも頼らないようにしようと
その基本的な物質に頼ることさえ捨てる
いわゆる純粋に心だけ残ると
それは決して人間にはもう想像できない
人間にこれさえ このルーパヴァチャラさえ想像できないんです
我々の知識は全部この現に必須の情報に固まっているんだから
私たちも じゃあ一人で妄想してると心だけではないかと
体と関係ないでしょうと
そうじゃないでしょ 妄想してるものが何ですかというと
聞いたものをもう味わったものを見たものでしょうに
ですから 我々の妄想は正真正銘の欲界
こちらでは妄想ではないんです
妄想はありえないんです
ただ 心は自分だけ波動を打つ始めるんです
物質と何の関係もなく
いわゆる体からもう完全に離れている状態
ですから 脳細胞からも完全に離れている状態
で 認識機能はある 知る機能
だから知るものは違いますよ
確かに 体から離れてあの京都を見ようということじゃないんだ
京都を見ようと思っちゃったら
目で見ることと同じだから
じゃあここを出て 体から心を離れて離してあげて
解放してあげて じゃあ京都を見ようではないかと
そういうのは色界であって
欲界であって だから今あっちこっちでこの
あのたまに出てくるこの
あのいながら他のところのことが見えますたよとかなんとかいうのは
じゃああれは無色界ではない
冗談じゃない あれは何のこともなく
ちょっとした現象 異常現象だけなんです
まあいつでも異常現象っていうのはあり得るんですからね
突然変異みたいなものっていうのは
ですから 仏教ではアルーパっていうのはすごい高い次元の心の世界
その場合は心だけ波を打つ
ですから このものは全然見ない
見えない もう捨ててるんです
天国はどうかだこと そんなこと見ない
全くもう何見てるんでしょうかね
何も見てないんです その場合は
ただ心の波打ってるだけ
説明すると分かりましたのはこれから
今日はね 今日じゃないんです
それはいくつでしたっけ
十二種類あるんです 次に四番目は出世間
この出世間というのは
この今まで説明した欲界
色界 無色界 全部世間なんです
存在の次元なんです このただ心唯一のみという存在であろうとも
存在なんですね 心は純粋に物質の働きから離れたんだからと言ったっても
心を知るという働きがあるんだから
我々は存在と呼んでですね
存在の世界 存在から存在から成り立っている世界は世間という
で 全くの存在を乗り越え
一切 だから煩悩 存在しているということは煩悩であって
ある波を打ちたいというエネルギーなんです
そのエネルギーは消える瞬間で
煩悩が消える瞬間 すべてのこの現象的な存在を感じていて
それはもう感じない瞬間で生まれる心に漏刻というというんですね
それは悟りの心なんですね
仏教の悟りの心 他の宗教の悟りの方は大体ほとんどルーパーワチラの世界で終わっちゃうんです
本物だったら 偽物だったらアマーチャーなんです
いわゆるインドの昔にいた仙人たちとかは
やっぱり偽物ではなかったんだからね
やっぱりアルーパワチラ
ルーパワチラの方の体験はあったでしょうね
ですから お釈迦様はそこら辺ちゃんと明確に説明をしているし
ちゃんと修行してちゃんと瞑想体験があるのはもう本物の体のある人と言えますからね
それはそちら辺の次元で完全に存在を捨てろうと
存在はいかなる状態であろうが
もう意味がないよと思ったところで煩悩消える
その時は仏教で言っている悟りが生まれてくる
涅槃の悟り その心には心は出世間心で八つあります
そうすると心は大体八十九
出ているんですね そこでこのまあ遊びみたいな感じで
この出世間の心は瞑想の世界だから
大体色界の次元で瞑想するんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想 欲界の次元じゃなくて
今なさっているような感じで
お釈迦様の時代ではこの色界の次元で瞑想のヴィパッサナーやらせたんです
ですから この自分が色界の
これ十五書いてますけど
それは五つのカテゴリー
三つありまして 洗浄する心は五つしかないんです
五つ ですから 色界の次元で瞑想するんだから
この色界の次元の心は五つありまして
その五つにこれを当てはめて八掛ける五で四十種類と言ってもいいんだよ
ですから この八あるいは四十出世間心は
四十は八掛ける五で で
こちらから色界からそれを作るんです
まあそこら辺そんなにもう関係そんなに難しいことじゃない
そのそこら辺まで勉強していくと
そういうことで 八十九か百二十九ですか
二十一 で 百二十一 という風に心を分けていますね
まだたくさんあるはずなんですけど
まあそんなもうくだらない心の分析はまあ結構ということで
海の水は一滴一滴稼げというならば
いくらでも稼がれますけど
別に意味がないでしょうに
ですから まあこれぐらいでいいんじゃないかと
太平洋とかね インド洋とかね
四つぐらいに分ければそれで十分だと
一滴一滴稼がなくても
でも太平洋と何とかインド洋とか言ったって
それまた繋げているでしょうに
ですから 海だと言ったっても
まあそれでも十分です
じゃあまああまり まあ一応どんどん進んでいきましょう
まああまりこの何といいますか
時間もなくなりますし
じゃあ今度からこの色界の心を説明します
色界じゃない 欲界の心
欲界の心で最初にこの不善心
不善心 タイ語でアクサラチッタというんですね
不善心 勉強してみましょう
不善心は十二種類あるんです
で いきなり見てください
仏教はやっぱり倫理学的に心を分析するんです
心理学的ではないんです
心理学は倫理学の枠の中で分析するんです
なぜかというと これは宗教でもあるし
心の分析は言っているのは修行を支えるためだけなんです
ちょっと瞑想の助けになるための目的で
他の目的はありません
治療する目的は全くない
そういうのは仏教には興味ない
ですから 何が悪ですか
何が善ですかと 結局心ですからね
体はただの機械的な物体だから
機械的物体には善も悪もないんだから
車に人が轢られても車は殺人になれませんし
運転した人がまあ捕まりますから
車には罪がない ただの機械だから
じゃあこの不善心の十二は
まず漏婆痴遍 ムーラと読みますですね
漏婆 ムーラ 痴遍 八ありまして
ドーサムーラチッペは二位で
ムーラムーラチッペはまた二位
十二になるんですね そういうふうに
漏婆は貪り 貪 ドーサは瞋
怒り ムーラは痴 無智 無明ですね
貪瞋痴に分けてます まあアビダンマ初めはそういうふうに丁寧に分析していくんだけど
それからまたものすごくややこしくなっちゃうんです
心の分析は 貪瞋痴に分けて
それから不貪不瞋不痴にちゃんと分けて善心説明した方がいいのに
そうは思い切ってないんです
じゃあとにかく貪瞋痴という漢字がご存知ですから
一応書いてください この場合は貪根
ムーラっていうのは根
元 根ですね 貪根痴と書けば大丈夫です
まあ一応 そういうことで
まあ貪瞋痴 瞋瞋痴 痴瞋痴と
となるんです そこら辺で私たちは一般的な知識で十分で
そういうきめ細かい言葉はどうでもいいんだけど
一応心が不善になるのは
悪い心になるのは あの貪瞋痴のせいなんですね
貪瞋痴っていうのは心の中のある心素なんです
心の中に溶けるものなんです
心は別に善悪もないで
水と同じ 水はお茶になるか紅茶になるかコーヒーになるかっていうのは
水の中に溶けるものによりますから
ですから心は別に罪も悪も何もない
ただの心 知ることだけ
そちらにむさぼりが入ったら悪い心になっちゃいますよと
怒りが入ったらそれまた悪い心ですよと
痴が 無知だったらそれまた悪い心ですよと
暗い心ですよと 汚れてる心ですよ
その汚れた心で行動すると危ないですよと
なぜ それは違う論理で
何か働きがそこの結果必ず出すんですね
何かは 何か消えると何かが現れるって
それはもうどうしようもないことで
因と果の流れが 今の瞬間の私が次の瞬間の私を作る
今ここにいる私が過去の私の結果なんですね
それをやめることはできません
それ消えちゃったら 今スマナサーラで次の瞬間は田中やもうタモリや誰かになるかもしれませんし
次の瞬間で 今は男性で次の瞬間で女性になる
次の瞬間犬になる わからなくなっちゃいますからね
そういうのはないんです
いくらかこの今の自分が次の自分という現象を作りますから
その因果法則はもう絶対的で
もうどうしようもないんですね
ですから この悪い心 こういう貪瞋痴の心が生まれたら
次の行動はそれによってもう変化するんですね
まあそういうことで これは一応不善心だと
なぜならば なぜ不善かというと
結果としては悪い結果
好ましくない結果を作る
その中にさらにある法則があって
生命が喜びを求めているんですね
刺激 快楽というか 喜びというか
喜というか 楽しむために生きてるんです
苦しむためではなくて
必死で楽しみを探し求めているんです
食べるのも歩くのも音楽を聴くのも服を着るのも
生きているのも楽しみたいだからなんです
そこでもし生命が楽しんじゃったならばどうなるんですか？もう生きていかなくてもいいんです
ですから いくら探しても見つからないのはもう何ですか
楽しみなんです だから延々と生き続けなくちゃいけないんです
見つかってないんだから
じゃあ見つかろうと いくらご飯食べても完璧
完全たる満腹感というか
満足感は得られない だからまた食べる
いくら生きていても完全に満足はしない
ですから また生まれる
そういうことで ものすごい基本というか
単純なことなんです この輪廻転生でも
今も私たちは不満でから
またまたやりたいんですね
納得 今の状態で納得いかないんですね
さらによくなりたいと
あるいはこれではダメだからもっと良くなりたいと
いつでもこの 何て言いますか
明るい明日があるよと思ってるんです
それ偉そうに言うんですね
この明るい明日があるというのはものすごい暗い概念なので
誰も気が付かないんです
今日は暗いということだから
それは俗世間の人々の言葉で
仏教ではそういう言葉がないんです
明るい明日のために頑張ろうと
それ永遠に明日だから
永遠に現在は暗いんですね
ですから 今日明るくせよと
ということでないと 明るくやろうではないかと
明日どうでもいいと 昨日どうでもいいと
いう状態でなければ 正しい生き方ではないんです
そう言っちゃったら なんて失礼な
大胆な 無責任な話ではないかとすぐ思っちゃうんです
明日はどうでもいいと言っちゃったら
すごい無責任でしょう
昨日 あ これどうでもいいんだと
昨日は そんな開き直れって冗談じゃないんだと
今までやったことはどうするんですかと
いうふうに思ったりするし
だから一般の人々いうのは過去を引き摺れと
現代を忘れろ 妄想を追えということなんですね
幻を追え 事実を忘れろ
過去を引き摺れと ものすごい暗いでしょ
[笑い]だから仏教の世界は全く違うんです
だから一般のこの心理学やらいろんなテキストなんか書く人々は明るいこと明るいというのを書くんだけど
決して誰も明るくはないんです
仏教の世界以外は ですから
たとえ死後天国に行きますからと死んじゃったら
いくらか仏教の世界で
この明るい宗教といえば浄土真宗なんですね
ものすごい簡単単純でも
まあもう死ぬことさえしていただければ
もう親さんですか お迎えに来て連れてきますと
だから我々にとっては死ぬことだけしてあげれば
もうそこまではどうしようもないんです
阿弥陀様も死ぬ前に連れて行かないんです
なんかもしかするとビザ取れないとかなんとかあるんでしょうね
で まあそれはそれで まあ仏教
宗教の中でもいくらか明るい宗教といえば浄土真宗だけなんです
それもものすごい単純でバカバカらしいなんですけど
他の宗教の人とはやっぱりもう死後の天国極楽っていうのを約束しちゃうんですね
ですから じゃあ現在についてどう喋りますかと
まあすごい暗いんですね
今についてはね そういうのは全部暗い話なんですね
ですから 本当に明るいんだったら
とっても明るくなければいけませんし
その明るさっていうのは現在
今の瞬間で得なくちゃいけない
だから明るい明日に頑張っちゃうんだから
今についてはいつでも不満なんですね
いつでも不満で ですから
さらに明日 今日は明日良くなると
明日やる 明日 だから明日いつでもあります
僕も子供たちと遊ぶと
このやりたくない約束は明日にするんです
で 子供はこの日にち変えて明日にやってきたら
もうあれはもうどうしたんですかと
僕は僕はどういう風に言ったんですか？と言ったら
先生言ったでしょ 明日なんとか明日でしょ
で言いますけどね そういうふうにも永遠にその約束をしないで済みます
で このみんな このいろんな迷信やら幽霊やらね
いろんな信じてますけど
本当に自分の中で面白い話があるんです
話というか 本当にもうあるんです
今はないんだけど なんか子供たちにも僕は知りませんだけど
なんとか病気が病気になるんですね
ごく普通の病気だと思いますけど
昔はそんなに医学とかなんとかとかないんだけど
それはなんとかの悪霊のせいで病気になるんだと
子供にしかどういう病気も経験ないんだからわかりませんし
で そこでこの家でこの玄関に書くんですね
なんとか病気は今日ではなくて明日ですよ
と書くんです 今日は今日は今日向こうの言葉ですごいかわいいんで
このまま今日はダメですけど
明日にしようという意味なんですね
その霊にメッセージなんですね
この悪霊にちょっとしたメモを書いておくんです
そこでなんでこう書きます？その子供を病気にして殺そうとしている霊が玄関から入ってくる看板が
今日はダメ 明日ですかと帰るんだそうです
で 次の日の夜 今日はダメに変わってやがって
それでその病気がうつるという時間
時間内で子供はもう何も病気なく回られますよという
だからこの面白い 面白いんだけど
それぐらい頭が悪い例かと
それは別の話なんですけど
文字が読めますかとかね
そこはこの迷信について関係ない話ですからね
例に文字が読めるかどうかとかね
文字ぐらい読めるんだったら今日と明日の区別ぐらい
ですから その中にはやっぱり理論は正しいんです
明日っていうのは絶対実現しないものなんです
そこら辺はみんな知ってるんです
明日っていうのは絶対永遠にダメということなんです
だから あの昔の人々がああいう風にすごい可愛い何かメッセージを例に書いておいて
そこでもその人々は無意識的に知ってるのは
明日っていうのは暗くて絶対現実化にはならないものっていうことなの
だから物は明日にするんじゃなくて
今にしろということなんです
そちらに入ってるメッセージは
ですから 簡単にこの迷信だからといって馬鹿にするのはそれで構いませんだけど
でもその中にもある事実はあるんです
ですから 明るい明日に頑張っちゃったら
まあ永遠に暗い そこで全ての生命が明るい明日に頑張りますから
永遠に不満で生きていなくちゃいけないんです
明るくなるのは明日だから
それをことで輪廻転生までするんです
死んでそれで終わってはいけませんでしょ
幸福は天国にあるんだから
そこを行かなくちゃいけないんですね
と言ったっても 心は今の心
その心を作るんだから
その人はいくら天国に行きたくたっても
どのように生きてきたんですかということによって
その心の回転が起こりますから
希望通りには天国には行けませんし
天国というところへ行ったっても
また同じことの繰り返しだから
苦しみの終わりがなくなっちゃうんですね
まあで とにかく仏教でこの暗いというのをこのそういう法則で不善というんで
とにかく生命が本当は喜びを味わいたい
その味わいたいものの違うものを味わう場合は
生き方がちょっとおかしいんではないかと
あなた生きてるのは楽しみために生きてるでしょ
でもあなたの生き方によっては苦しみが味わってるんだと
ですから あなたの生き方は不善ですよと
この善不善っていうのは
これ絶対的な意味ではなくて
そういう意味なんです
苦しみが味わって快感だったらしょうがないんです
地獄に落ちて快感だよというならば
地獄は天国になってしまっちゃいますからね
天国は地獄になってしまっちゃうし
とにかく生命が喜びを味わいたい
そのために生きている
でも その喜びを味わえない生き方が不善という
苦しみが味わい生き方が不善という
そこで貪瞋痴に基づいて心が動くならば不善という
ということは 貪瞋痴に基づいて心が活動すると
必ず不幸に苦しみを味わうことになるということ
時間は飛びますけど このぐらい 10 分 15 分で説明できませんかね
で あのあと 10 分ぐらいでこの説明します
そんなに難しくないんです
まあ全部覚えなきゃ後で後で苦しみますけどね
まあそれは私じゃないんだから別に構いません
この貪瞋痴 貪瞋痴のことを 8種類あるんですね
どのように8種類になりますかというと
まず貪瞋痴は 2種類に分けるんです
2つに分けるんです 一つはソーマナサと
パーリ語でソーマナサというんです
まあソーマナサ ウペッカーだけで覚えたって構いません
この 2つに分ける ソーマナサは 4つあります
ウペッカーの心が安らぎます
その場合は そうむなしさっていうのは喜びがあるという意味なんです
サハガタっていうのはあるということ
SAHAGATA そうむなしさっていうのは喜び
喜という字を書いているみたいですね
テキストでは 喜 喜び サハガタというのはありますと
ウペッカーっていうのは
あのテキストでは捨という捨てるという漢字書いてますけど
意味としては別に喜びというものは別にない
別に悲しみあるわけじゃない
苦しみあるわけでもない
普通なんですね いわゆる苦もない楽もない状態
普通な状態 ニュートラルな状態
で それで喜びを感じる心が安らぎまして
ニュートラル的な心が安らぎます
それは欲の心なんですね
あ 大変なことを忘れました
ローバって何ですかと
で ローバの裏のローバ
これはトン・トン・コン・シンですね
トンというのは貪りというのは
あの また仏教の定義は違うんです
もう何でも違う定義になっちゃいますけど
あの貪っているという意味ではないんです
まあその意味もあります
でも貪りっていうのは
何か見て その見るものは自分がこの見て楽しいんですね
見たいんですね いわゆる見て抵抗は生まれません
何か聞いてすごい心で何か抵抗生まれたったら
それは聞きたくない音なんですね
聞いて ああまあいいんじゃないかと受け入れる
生命が受け入れる 受け入れられる
受け入れたい対象について欲というんですね
対象 まあそういうものですね
いわゆる認識して 嫌っという気持ちは生まれません
いいんじゃないかと生まれる気持ちなんですね
もっと違う定義します
対象は受け入れる 心の中に
離れない 取る 掴む 対象を見るもの
聞くもの 味わうもの で
こういうふうに考えるとわかりやすい
例えば口の中に自分が食べたい美味しいものを入れると
ああいいと気持ちいいと受け入れるんですね
自分が全然もう食べたくもない
美味しくもないものを口に入れちゃうと
例えば まあ生きているあの蛇とかね
生きたまんまで あるいは蛇というよりもあのトカゲとかね
ヤモリでもいいんだけど
人を捕まって口に入れてみて
ああ美味しいと 思うかどうか分かりませんだけど
みんな魚なんか生きたまんまで口に入れると美味しいと言うんだからね
で あるいはものすごい苦くて
もう人間食べてもいけない
強烈な苦いものを口に
舌に入れちゃったら 口に入れちゃったら拒絶反応起こるでしょ
自然に それの反対に食べたいものを
お菓子でもケーキでも何でも口に入れたら拒絶反応は起こしません
受け入れる ものすごいもうノコギリでこの鉄板とか
もう切る音とかが耳に入ると
すごくもう体までもう毛が立つような悪い気持ちが生まれちゃうんですね
でも誰かが同じ鉄なんですけど
バイオリンの弦を棒で弾いてると
その音はジーッと聞いていると
そうなるんですね あの
ありますね あの鉄を切る場合は特別なこのノコギリというんですか
このソーですか ありまして
あれでキャーキャーキャーとやると
もう本当にもう心臓までもう嫌な気持ちがする
同じ鉄のね 金属の音なんですけど
バイオリンにしたっていうのは
あれは別に抵抗はない
その 2種類なんですね
だから対象を見て心が嫌と受け入れる対象
その世界はむさぼりと欲と漏馬というんです
ですから対象を見たら楽しみのは当たり前なんですね
綺麗な音楽を聴いたら心は喜びを感じる
ですからそうまなさと言うんです
喜びを感じない場合は怒り感じますか？いい別に
例えば BGMとして音楽が流れてるでしょ？スーパーやマーケット
ああいうところで うるさくて誰も聞いてないんですね
でもその音楽は耳に入る
入っても もうきれいな音楽だとは踊ったりはしない
あまり人はない時は このコンビニエンスストアのいる人々は踊ってますけど
有線で流れて音楽を聴いて
それはもうたまたまなんですけどね
昼の時とかはそんな踊ってる暇がないんですね
でもあの音楽をその時嫌いだからスイッチを切ろうということはしない
ですから楽しみがない場合は普通の感情
苦もなく楽もなく 心が生まれる
ですから この自分の心はむさぼりかないかと理解する場合は感覚でまず言っちゃわなくちゃいけない
自分が楽しがっているんだったら
それは全部欲の世界 瞑想している体験以外
瞑想して全ては嫌になって
この何もない心の状態を喜ぶと
この逆に心戻ってるの
逆というか反対方向へ
その楽しみだけが欲の世界じゃないんです
それ以外は欲の世界 もうありますけど
もう将来それ説明になります
いつかわかりません で
楽しみがない場合はこういうウペッカー
シャーの感情 不苦不楽の感情
感情でまず別れようとする
次にこれまた 2つに分ける
大丈夫だから本当に長いのですね
こちらも同じなんです
これどういう こういうふうに読むんです
ディッティガタサンパユッタ
ディッティガタヴィッパユッタ
この 2番目にもディッティガタサンパユッタ
ディッティガタヴィッパユッタと分かれるんです
じゃああの早くいきます
ディッティっていうのは見という仏教用語を書いてるんです
この見るという漢字書いて
この見という漢字なんですよ
ディッティが 見がある
見がないと 見の説明は次にします
このですから こちらも見がある心と見がない心と
で 見というのはだいたい意見と同じなんです
意見 概念 見解 立場 何か考え方とかね
だいたいそのような同じ意味なんです
まあテキストには伝統的な解釈入ってますから
そこら辺は分かりやすいんですから
それなりに読んでみてください
私はこのものすごい徹底的